[Musique]
les mots
[Applaudissements]
j'appartiens de la salle
et elle attend
on se tue cartonne merci beaucoup merci
déclaration je vais pas vous faire un
peu fallait pas
[Musique]
valet
paris
ils ont fait de la délation il fait
désormais payer pour leur participation
dans l'émission doré plus voice marouane
où un homme à voir avec le rythme je
voulais ça en fait avec ça at il dit ça
n'était pas envie de faire sourire et sa
bonne soupe à moi je suis passé tout le
week end je pense à toi j'ai dit qu'elle
kiffe lundi rester là bas j'avais quand
même un grand plateau je voulais quitter
le tour tout l'équipe et on le sait
voilà je le dis ce sont préférés voilà
deux mois de mes enfants ils sont comme
des oufs
cyberlink est flatté cheveux extension
est en extension
qu'ils en font des tonnes
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une question pour marois alors moi
c'est quand la dernière fois qu un coup
de coeur pour un mec aulas a et jamais
réellement eu le coup de coeur pour un
pour un mec à la 20 e en bons et qui les
rendent bien non l'émission n'est pas
terminée je pense que j'ai encore le
devoir et ton style autour des 900
requis par israël mais aussi à table
r d
[Applaudissements]
je t'embrasse simon bercy des
classements sont 1
gilles duceppe plus de 10 millions de ce
crime pour ceux qui dakar tôt et toi ma
chérie bien sûr c'est pour toi single
dort plus de 2000
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]